this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart stamps.com candid and
manscaped more on that later let's get
into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media listen
the night pants nation tours kicking off
september 16th through the 18th in
phoenix arizona all right this is a
gratitude tour like i said i've sat in
this room for the last year and a half
and now i'm coming out to see you all
right uh so we got phoenix september
30th to october 2nd i'll be in
indianapolis i am going to do some dates
with segora and uh
only ones in 2021 i'm going to do in
vegas october 8th and 9th
i'll be in baltimore october 23rd i will
be headlining the brea california improv
october 28th i'll be in arlington
virginia november 10th through the 13th
cleveland december 9th through the 11th
la jolla december 17th through the 19th
and there's more dates on the calendar
already we got arnold excuse me we got
austin we got kansas city we got
vancouver we got edmonton and we're
adding and adding so
please come out see me the night pants
nation tour wear your night pants to the
show if you don't have them we're gonna
have them come out and get your night
pants y'all alright uh please make sure
you subscribe to the youtube means
everything to us over here all right
it's just a simple subscribe but you
love the show you're watching it
subscribe anyway all right the patreon
continues to grow i know you guys are
seeing these episodes these promos are
out of control
uh the stories are too so if you or
someone you know has that story that has
to be heard submit it at honeydewpodcast
gmail.com we do have a lot of
submissions but i promise you we're
going through everything so be patient
pay attention to your inboxes hopefully
we get to do an episode together it's
five bucks a month all right you're also
getting the honeydew a day early ad free
at no additional cost and you do get
access to the entire back library and
you get the audio option as well all
right all that for five bucks but if you
sign up for a year you get over a month
free all right i gotta remind you about
the ringtones they're available on
itunes i know you guys are snatching
them up probably scaring your pets and
friends but uh they are available on
itunes just go to ryansickler.com and
you'll see how to get there you just
search my name on itunes scroll down to
ringtones boom they're there that's it
the athletes we got the honeydew
athletes y'all we've got four coming up
on five we got marcus everett my bow
fisherman
okay we got kaden wood my d2 pitcher we
got beck adler my big wave surfer and
we've got maverick reed my my cowboy now
you all know what we do here we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers there is nobody i've been
wanting to have on this podcast as dark
as this next guy who actually his smile
brings a light to my damn face ladies
and gentlemen for the first time on the
honeydew please welcome anthony jeselnik
everybody welcome to the honeydew i feel
like just saying it's my first time is
pretty optimistic
the idea you would get me here again
listen bro you get to get you'll get
that haircut again in a few months we'll
have you back we'll work around your
sketch
uh first of all thank you for being here
thank you for having me i uh i know we
go back a ways in comedy
uh and i'm super stoked to have you on
because like i say you know people but
we talked about it before that we were
recording comedy is a solo sport so yes
you only get to know them so much yeah
but also like i think we when we kind of
started together at the same time and
you were one of those guys i don't know
if you felt this way about me but if i
saw you at a show i was like relieved i
was like okay like we've got good people
on the show nice things
we're in a sea of hopeless losers who
are never going to make it and so i
would like to see
this guy's funny like all right cool
like if i said you were sigur i was like
all right good like jay larsen or
somebody was like okay like i'm on a
good lineup tonight but uh that was i
never know you felt that way about me
ever yeah no cause i've i've sat and had
conversations with you about other
comedians and when i leave all i think
is
what the [ __ ] does he say about me oh my
god
i don't want to know nothing bad uh i
believe you dude yeah always i mean look
i
i can i tell you this though i
you know i always talk about you the two
the two jokes that always stand out in
my head and i i don't want to do this
but i'm gonna do it because they're so
[ __ ] good and it's what i remember
and it's literally the world cafe it
might be the first time i met you might
have been the world cafe it was
definitely around that time and that was
a great wednesday night because swardson
would roll anybody and i feel the same
way like okay this is a good show you
know i knew back then if i was the best
comic on the show it was a horrible show
back then i knew that you know
but um i believe your joke went um
i'm pretty sure my brother-in-law's
beating my sister i don't have proof but
her cooking's gotten a lot better did i
get it right yeah pretty much
pretty much pretty good for
years i remember i was gonna do that
joke on premium blend like the first
like tv appearance i had like here's my
list of jokes and i've got maybe like 15
jokes and they're like you can't tell
this joke
and i'm like listen this joke is like
this joke works like i understand it's
like domestic violence and it's also the
world's so silly and absurd like let me
talk to standards and practices and they
get me on the phone with these two women
on like a speaker call
and i'm trying to convince them that
this is funny and they're like they're
just getting madder and madder and
they're like i get it it's like a joke
your like uncle would tell who's not
very funny and i'm like so that makes me
mad
and i'm like no this is this joke is
fine and like it's about women getting
beaten and i'm like
no okay and finally they were like you
know what we'll let you do the joke and
and we'll see in the edit and i was like
i know what's gonna happen you're about
to cut this out but i will never defend
a domestic violence joke against two
women ever again it's like
it's not really domestic violence
because what you say is
i'm pretty sure there's doubt here in in
the setup yeah she may have just gotten
better at cooking but hey i know one
thing cooking's better i'm not saying
yeah but i am saying this i even think i
like i haven't seen any bruises you know
it's like there's nothing like if the
only evidence is your cooking's gotten
better then i was like no one's getting
just discovered
no one's getting beaten in that
not
joke
nobody but people are eating well and
that's i mean come on man so that was
the one i really loved and i like a
[ __ ]
was at a writing gig and i told that
joke and there were three women in the
group who might have been on that same
call did not fi and i was like nah
listen they were like we don't want to
hear it i was like all right i'll just
go oh anytime i've been like
in like a car or something like the
driver was like what are you all you're
a comedian like tell me a joke it always
goes so
so badly like unless you like get to see
the whole movie you know what i mean
it's like of course the scene of someone
getting murdered they're just like this
is horrifying but if you're like
watching that guy rape nine kids yeah oh
okay
yeah um the other one too that i tell i
still tell it is um i'm
close on this one i think is um i told
my mom that when i turned 18 i wanted to
get a motorcycle and she said absolutely
not that when my uncle was 18 he died in
a horrific motorcycle accident and i
could just have his i mean your timing
is way off
and you the wedding's not perfect but
yeah i get people get the point yeah
it's like that was that was like my
first joke where i was like oh but i
remember this yeah yeah that was the
first one that was like turn me on to
you i would sit in the back of the world
cafe and be like who the [ __ ] is this
guy you've always reminded me of like
this um
like a dark steven right you know and
you did it your way i remember hearing a
story about you submitted your jokes for
your half hour you didn't even shoot you
just cause it's one after the other you
just wrote them and submitted it that
way which i don't think anybody no had
ever not only done if they did they
probably looked at them like who's this
[ __ ] [ __ ] they would because they
would take the tape and then they would
transcribe it themselves and i was like
let me just do that for you i know
exactly what i'm gonna be saying here
you go that way they couldn't like if
they that way if they got mad about a
joke
i would say if you heard it
you would be okay with it and they'd be
like okay you can put it in and we'll
edit around whatever but like i remember
my half hour they edited out the
motorcycle joke it was my second joke
and i was furious i was like that's one
of my best jokes ever and you took it
out for time
for time
like oh
the half hour god damn um all right
enough of that i i just want to tell you
how uh you know we do go back a ways
that i remember that's made an impact on
me as joke writers go out there and
you're absolutely at the top of the
[ __ ] list so please after all that
promote plug everything you'd like uh
just i'm right now i'm just uh you know
running around town doing sets trying to
build up the next hour but i've got a
podcast of my own called jrvp the just
linux and rosenthal vanity project my
best friend from college uh greg
rosenthal was an nfl analyst we uh we
started doing a podcast like at the nfl
network like they kind of snuck me in
and it was like every week he was about
to get fired because of what we talked
about in the podcast and then they
kicked this out
and we started doing it on our own as as
the jeslik and rosenthal vanity project
with all things comedy and uh it's been
it's been great we're about i think i'm
taping episode 118 tonight damn all
right but yeah i remember when you did
what when did it switch for you where
you're like okay i need to podcast what
was the switch for you when you're like
all right i got to do this it wasn't a
need it was a let me do something with
my friend and greg has like a a podcast
called around the nfl that does really
well so it was like okay we can like
work together in a way that it's like
not i'm carrying him like he brings
something yeah i know i definitely know
who he is i'm an nfl fan so and then
when uh i eventually i got to deal with
comedy central for like a bunch of
different [ __ ] like a bunch of like a
show and other things and the podcast
was one of it and they overpaid by like
an insane amount so i was like all right
let's go let's do this and it was like
to get the tv show
a production company and then when the
comedy central imploded and everything
went to hell uh then it was the pandemic
and i'm like well let's keep this go
let's find another studio to go through
and keep it going and i i truly enjoyed
it it's a lot like the justin look
offensive was when we highlight we talk
about our week and our friendship and
then we talk about like stories from
college and then we talk about just like
the craziest news stories of the week
like tonight we're opening with this uh
i don't know if you heard about this
woman who was on a zoom call like with
her uh like a business and she shot she
gets shot and then looking for the video
she goes down and then it's just her
toddler standing behind her holding the
gun no like everyone can see it on the
zoom
that i'm just like we're talking about
this this is like this is the main story
because if you're on a zoom call
like if i'm talking do you want a zoom
call and you drop and i see a toddler
behind you with a gun i'm looking behind
me i'm like maybe they've risen up
they're all here
maybe they're coming for all of us but
you don't know
but i love that like i just find the
absurd angle in a dark story and run
with it
yeah i mean that's what you do
i um
all right so i want to talk to you about
your upbringing stuff but real quick
where did you go to college tulane
university okay down in new orleans yeah
all right yeah that was a hell of a time
so you went from pittsburgh to new
orleans that's probably a culture shock
huge you've been down there already to
know i had never been like i rarely left
pittsburgh as a kid because i was the
oldest of five kids it was hard to
travel like we didn't go on like spring
break vacations and stuff like ocean
city maryland you know
you are away for two weeks every sunday
all right so we're waiting hold on no
you weren't two weeks we only got one
but we would go during hurricane season
because it was cheaper so half of the
time and i was like we have the worst
two for one i'm like our family has the
worst luck with vacations then i
realized no the last like the end of the
summer is when this happens that's why
we got a deal on the place
awesome and uh pack up the car hurricane
sandy's coming oh my god that you guys
go on vacation yeah but i i never i
never saw two i never saw new orleans i
went down for my first day oh my god i
just knew it was gonna be from what i'd
seen in pop culture and stuff i just
knew new orleans college in new orleans
was going to be the best four years of
my life and i was right yeah yeah you
loved it loved it
i mean graduate i mean the fact that i
graduated in four years was a goddamn
miracle like during my graduation
ceremony i'm
having my parents meet my friends and
they're like everyone's just like i
can't believe you graduated like i just
can't [ __ ] believe it
what's your mate uh what's your degree i
was a lit major okay yeah and um
let's start let's go back so you're one
of five born in pittsburgh what did your
parents do my dad was an attorney you're
the youngest you said i'm the oldest
okay my dad's an attorney uh and my mom
was the housewife because she was just
raising all these kids they had five
kids in seven years god damn yeah are
anyone twins no holy [ __ ] yeah like a
year and a half between each one of us
it's like me three girls and my
brother's the youngest like i don't know
if you know this it's you know there are
billions and billions of people so you
would think it's easy to have a kid but
when you really want to it's not always
so easy so to have five in seven years i
mean god damn your dad's fertilish or
your mom or both i mean i assume i
assume it was it was a team effort yeah
but yeah my dad's catholic opening a big
family my mom came from a big family and
they just wanted to
keep cranking them out and i can't
believe like i was here people who have
kids they're like one is great two is
manageable once you go to three it's
like your life is a living hell because
you don't have enough people to handle
everybody that having five is is just
unimaginable uh even what were you in
the 80s are you an 80s baby i was born
at the end of 78. think about that yeah
70 [ __ ] eight in the next from 78 to
85
there's seven or five of you coming in
holy [ __ ] i mean i think about now like
i remember my dad
like i'm 42 now i'm like
my dad was 42
i was in like
i was in like seventh grade imagine
having a seventh grader like right now
listen when my dad was 42 he died so
he i've outlived him he's i mean like my
dad would have trade places all the time
right now though it's straight in place
i think about all the time i'm 48 i'm
like all right
huh i outlived my dad but i have a i
have a six year old you know what i mean
my dad these guys were in their what
probably twenties when they started
having kids for your dad or maybe early
thirties yeah i think yeah like late
late twenties for my dad early twenties
for my mom yeah pretty quick pretty
quick i mean that's young you know you
look back at it now man we're anchoring
down i mean let's get you either do it
early and like crank them out and so we
can be like you know we can have our
freedom later on or you do it late and
that's just the rest i tell my
daughter's mother all the time like why
didn't you just tell me you wanted a kid
and wanted to redecorate your place i
probably would have said yeah you didn't
need to move me in kick me you didn't
need to do all that i'd have paid for
some paints and pillows you know what
i'm saying i'm not an [ __ ]
but also if i known it was gonna go down
like this i would have done that [ __ ] in
my 20s you know what i mean i would have
young knees right now chasing a toddler
and [ __ ]
um but so you're the oldest of five and
what was it are your parents still
together yeah they still alive still
alive still together wow yeah all right
and what was it like being the oldest
were you were you made to be responsible
or were they just hardest on you or how
was it i i they were harder on me than
everybody else because my sisters were
like beautiful girls but just like kind
of little
crazy is the wrong word but they were
rambunctious and so my parents gave them
a lot of grace but were always chasing
them around and they expected me to kind
of wrangle a little more and i was very
protective of my sisters if they ever
got into a fight like i was there i was
dealing with like trying to keep older
guys from sleeping with them in high
school and younger girls from trying to
beat them up um but i wasn't a great
like example i wasn't like setting the
example i wasn't like a great babysitter
that i think my parents were just kind
of like why are you like this and i
definitely got the harsher punishments i
was just grounded a lot as a kid but
once i left like people had free reign
because i think i was just a difficult
uh a difficult kid to raise so what like
what's the age of your sisters under you
then
like how close like
a couple years about a year this is
about a year and a half in between each
of us so my youngest brother is seven
years younger so when you're a senior
they're
junior and sophomore then i had yeah
i i had two sisters and my once was a
freshman one was a a junior i believe
another senior or a sophomore so yeah i
was only in high school with with two of
them and were you active in sports i
played lacrosse uh in high school i
liked lacrosse a lot uh swam for a
couple years before that it was terrible
baseball terrible football like i loved
backyard football but once like i put on
the pads and then like you're a lineman
i was like i hate this so much like i
want nothing to do with this like never
bitter no but i was like six i was like
six feet tall you know at that age that
they just threw me in the line and i
hated it like who do you block on this
play and i'm like the same guy on every
play like the guy right in front of me
and they're like no man you're not
getting in the game
he's the slide to your left right yeah i
know i no idea how it works
um so
what age do you start um like were you
did you act out were you you said you
weren't good
when you said you weren't a good student
was it just
because a lot of people tell me that but
but
we're defined by letters on our grades
just because you didn't test well or
whatever
you know was school easy for you and it
wasn't enough to entertain you or was it
actually difficult for you it was just i
was bored and i didn't understand why i
had to deal with science and math and
stuff and i just i i ran my mouth you
know like i started a montessori school
my my mom like one day was i'm like
hanging out with my mom my mom's my best
friend and i'm a little kid and she's
like hey do you want to go to a place
where they have like scissors and paper
and colored pencils and you can like you
can play and i was like yeah let's do
that and she just drops me off at
montessori school and for the next four
years of my life i'm doing this that i
was like [ __ ] i would have said no if i
thought i would wait until kindergarten
yeah but by the time i got into first
grade i could read better than most of
the kids in the class but they said
montessori school i was such a problem
like i was just distracting all the
other kids the only thing that would
calm me down was to read to me and they
had like the the main the principal had
her father come in like an old retired
guy would come in and just read to me
for like two hours a day no matter what
it was yeah just me i would just sit
there and i would like let the class
have peace and listen to whatever i just
loved reading and books and then once i
learned how to read that was kind of my
my outlet so i was like this i was the
class clown in honors classes so it
which drove people great gosh like i
remember one year i failed math i failed
a second semester of calculus honors
calculus and i've got to go to summer
school and i assumed it's like i'd never
been before i assume it's like
somebody's teaching you math and they're
like no here's the textbook go through
like do the homework do the homework
just so you learn the stuff and when you
say you're ready for the test we'll give
you that test and then you go into the
next chapter and since it's the second
semester i've got to start at the
beginning
i can't just learn from the second half
so i'm going through and i'm like
the quicker i do this the quicker i'm
out of here and i ended up going getting
like an acing this [ __ ] like once you
actually do the work like aced it in two
weeks an entire year's worth of math
holy [ __ ] and they just gave me a
passing grade instead of uh and i didn't
get changed my first grade first
semester but i was like oh i could be
good if i just applied myself and that's
what drove everyone crazy it drove my
parents nuts they're like you can do all
of this you're just choosing not to but
i used my time to read i really liked
creative writing i got good grades in
that but i was just i was i was a
problem
and i thought i realized early on that
if i made the teacher laugh you couldn't
get in trouble
if i'd like just
popped off in class and the teacher was
like mad at me it's like you're going
down the hall but if the teacher laughs
it's like [ __ ] anthony like okay like
we'll give that to you but like please
just let me do my job yeah that i was i
i don't think teachers loved me so some
did but a lot were like oh this guy's
ruining my life so you were a problem
but just for school you were you getting
arrested or are you nothing none of that
no never maybe like they catch me with
cigarettes or something you know or like
a can of beer but nothing nothing bad so
did you ever get caught with that in
school cigarettes or a can of beer
because i had a kid one time george wilk
i'll never forget this he this
[ __ ] brought a six pack of moose
head beer that's the only time i've ever
had moosehead and put it so we had these
lockers and all of us would do the thing
where
you know it was three numbers but we
would do the first two so in between
classes you only had you know like a
minute and a half you'd run by you turn
it to that one number
pop it open throw your [ __ ] in and he at
two o'clock he's got a six-pack there's
a six-pack of moose head sitting in my
locker because all you had to do was
open up the thing and then flick the top
little lever open i was like what the
[ __ ] are you doing and i didn't want to
get it out like i was scared you know i
ended up getting it out my backpack and
hustling that [ __ ] out but man it scared
the [ __ ] out of me oh i never would like
they were like there was that group of
kids who like smoked in the bathroom or
like smoked outside but they weren't my
friends i didn't i barely smoked weed
until i was well into college because it
just like there were it was like the
jocks or the deadheads yes and i was
didn't really fit in with either but i
was definitely much more of a jock than
a deadhead yeah for sure like our my
senior year they we voted on what our
class song was going to be
and the winner by a large majority was
jamming by bob marley and i would be
furious every morning they would play it
before the announcements in school and i
was like these [ __ ] hippie
[ __ ] like jack my whole senior
year
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor upstart if
you're carrying a credit balance month
after month it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt and upstart
can help you make that final payment so
you can get ahead if you dread looking
at your credit card statement you're not
alone deck and field crippling but
upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment i say it every time
i know you guys are using it that's why
upstart keeps coming back you keep
emailing me tell me the great rate
you're getting and i'm excited for you
man i wish i had something like this
back when i was in debt upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and is expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to find you a smarter rate
for your loan and with a 5 minute online
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans between 1 000 to 50 000
and you can receive your funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com honeydew
don't forget to use my url to let them
know i sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit your
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
honeydew our next sponsor is stamps.com
are you still going to the post office
are you still paying full price for
postage well thanks to stamps.com you
don't have to anymore you can mail and
ship anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters you can
ship packages and you can pay less a lot
less with discounted rates from usps ups
and more shout out to ups baltimore hub
primary one joe avenue stamps.com saves
businesses thousands of hours and tons
of money
every year all right stamps.com brings
the services of the u.s postal service
and ups right to your computer it's a
must-have for any business whether
you're a small office sending invoices
or a side hustle etsy shop shipping out
orders or just navigating this hybrid
work life stamps.com can handle it all
with ease i tell you guys when i used to
do the craft feast and we would ship
shirts out back then we use stamps.com
all the time i'll personally sit there
weigh them on the scale print it out on
the labels boom sent them out it was it
was great it's so easy i never had to go
to the post office ever you just simply
use your computer to print you official
us postage 24 7 for any letter any
packages any class of mail anywhere you
want to send once your mail is ready you
schedule a pickup or you drop it off
it's that simple with stamps.com you get
discounts up to 40 off post office rates
and up to 66 percent off of ups shipping
rates not to mention stamps.com is a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder nearly 1 million small
businesses already use stamps.com stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with my promo code honeydew you
get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale there's no long-term
commitments or contracts so just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
honeydew that's stamps.com promo code
honeydewstamps.com never go to the post
office again now let's get back to the
do so you um you told me you got into a
little bit of trouble in school yes okay
so i i would get into trouble and the
thing was like when i made jokes when i
was the class clown i was kind of like i
am now where i wasn't just like making
fun of like you i can see your underwear
i was like doing dead baby [ __ ] back
then i believe that like freaked people
out that they were like this is a
problem and like
let me stop you and interrupt you just
to ask you this do you have any memory
of something you said to a teacher where
you got them to laugh and they let you
slide do you remember the only one i
remember like specifically because it
was like the first time it happened
where it was like an aha moment i'm in
second grade
and this one we're like doing show and
telling this one girl stands up and says
my family and i are moving we're leaving
like pittsburgh and we're going to and i
forget what the city was but it was some
like like
like total [ __ ] like billy joel like
wrote a song about it and then was like
it's too mean
that's too mean like i'm not gonna i'll
do allentown instead
and
she gets going on and the kids are all
like ooh wow like she's just going to
europe and i just go like
send us a postcard
and the teacher and the teacher starts
laughing and is like calls my parents to
be like this was like i'm not mad this
was this was so funny that he said this
and then i realized like oh that's like
that's great yeah that's great but a lot
a lot of sarcasm and a lot of dark dark
sarcasm you know but always pushing the
boundaries within school and that sort
of place yeah like doing the things that
would like make my friends laugh like
you shouldn't be saying that but i'm
saying it anyway like i would just do it
in class thinking that it was like smart
enough to be okay and i just didn't
realize how much i was freaking people
out like i have to like preface by
saying like this was before columbine
my high school my school experience is
very different if i go to school after
columbia i'll bet you all of ours as
well yes because then it was like if
you're the weird one like the people are
extra concerned and they weren't like
quite like that and i wasn't dressed in
all black either like i wasn't one of
those but i was definitely like a lot of
my jokes were violent you know if i was
doing a report for school it was on
something violent that happened that you
would write about that yeah and i would
get into detail like she was tied to a
post and raped every day for like four
years and then when she was pregnant
they lit her on fire like isn't it crazy
the teacher's like i'm like it was in
the news like i didn't make it up right
this isn't creative writing but it was
like like this is this is uncomfortable
i'm like that's bosnia man they're
[ __ ] up
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so what did you do what
happened okay so the story like the the
story that i mean it really is a
formidable thing in my life that i've
even like thought about talking about on
stage but i'm like it's almost too real
that not that i wouldn't want to make it
funny but that like i don't think people
would even believe me
so like go do you go back a little bit
before it's like let's say i am 11 12
years old and i'm visiting mississippi
i'm visiting my grandparents in
mississippi with my entire family
and one day uh we go to like a flea
market like my parents want to go
antiquing and they just hand each kid 20
bucks and then like go do your thing and
there's nothing for a 12 year old boy
there i remember there was like one
stand that had like nazi memorabilia
like like in the thing and i was like
this is like should i buy some of this
just to like as like a crazy thing not
that i would have any nazi tendencies
but like that's
a [ __ ] up thing to have but it was
like this giant black guy behind the
glass that i was like this is a trick
this is like yeah this is like coming in
you're gonna i'm gonna be like hey how
much is that and he's just gonna like
smash me in the face
something okay that's off limits and i'm
walking around there's like a guy in the
back who has knives these knives lined
up under a glass case and i don't mean
like pocket knives like utility knives
this is like a [ __ ] rambo knife
that's like i remember this survival
knife
huge survival like there's a screw-off
cap with the compass on the top and all
the knives
but it had like a grip and then a thing
that you could hit that would take the
knife into the middle so you could like
punch
knife people with it
it was insane
the blade would swivel into the front
like it was on a grip god and it was
just huge like it was like like nothing
you would ever take with you unless you
were going hunting okay uh but i this
it's 20 bucks with the with the case and
the sharpener and i'm like great
sharpener he's throwing it i buy it no
one ever asks me what i bought at the at
the the thing i just put in my backpack
don't tell anyone and i bring it home
and i just like show my friends when
they come over because it was like how
did you hide it how'd you i had a little
hiding place in my and i lived in the
basement but i mean getting it back well
how'd you hide because we drove so i
just stuck it in my luggage and we
wouldn't have to worry about an airplane
or anything
and it just stayed hidden i never even
took it out when i went out with friends
like i remember reading the outsiders
yeah in school like after that every kid
wanted a knife everybody wanted to
switch blade or some kind of knife they
would carry
it with them no one ever would fight
with it you would throw in the bushes if
somebody came to fight you but this was
too big for that that i just like kept
it just like locked away
and then cut to like eighth grade
i i truly like i just want twenty
dollars i wanna buy this girl i'm seeing
at the time a cd and i wanna say
i wanna say the cd was colored me back
i love it i saw them live and comments
she was a big color me bad fan it was
either color me bad or paula abdul
listen bro that was the concert
i took my cousin to the cap center it
was paula have to color me man and
somebody i don't remember who the [ __ ]
the one was like
yeah i was like i need i need to buy
this cd i would walk to the mall and i'm
like i just don't have 20 bucks so i
asked my friends who are all like have
seen this life i'm like do you does
anybody want to buy a knife and my
friends had more money than me and one
guy's like yeah i'd love to and i'm like
okay i'll bring him to school tomorrow
during lunch we'll go in the bathroom
i'll show it to you 20 bucks
during lunch i bring it in we go into
the bathroom and he sees it and as i'm
putting it away a seventh grader walks
in the bathroom and just sees it for
like a split second where i'm like did
he see anything i don't know but he
turned around and walked right out
you're not in a stall you're just out
we're just out
i mean i don't know why here he is it
was literally just like a second like
here look at this it wasn't like he was
like testing it out on [ __ ]
and i get the 20 bucks i go back to
lunch and the principal comes up to me
he's like anthony let's talk and he's
got kind of a smile on his face quick
that quick like the kid went right to
the principal and was like hey anthony's
got a knife
and he's like you know we're not allowed
to bring knives to school and i'm like i
know like knowing like you can search me
there's no knife and he's like
someone saw you with the knife and i'm
like okay i'm not gonna lie to you i
just brought it here i was just selling
it i sold it to a friend and he's like
smiling because it's not like i attacked
someone with a knife or they like i was
gonna get in a fight later and i had
this knife and he's like who'd you sell
it to i'm like i can't tell you that but
what i will do is i'll go back to the
guy get it from him give him his money
back and give the knife to you and he's
like okay just give it to me it's not to
go any further than this but if you if
you want it back your parents have to
come and get it which is i'm like yeah
yeah yeah keep the knife enjoy it yeah
i'm never doing this so i don't want to
get it
boring hunting with it my friend
understands he's happy i didn't sell him
out
give it to the principal he's like thank
you
an hour later i get called down to the
office and he's like i'm sorry
but in the past hour everyone has found
out about this teachers are asking about
the knife
they want to see the knife anthony has a
knife what's going on
we have to suspend you
and at the end of the suspension we have
to have a meeting with your parents
and i'm like i guess i'll keep tonight
like i'm like
all right man like this is gonna be
this is gonna be tough but i like i go
home my parents pick me up and they're
like a knife and they're everyone's
assuming like a pocket of course you
know everyone's assuming you're in
eighth grade yes a little one blade out
yeah not the swivel [ __ ] gutter here
and i'm like listen i just came to i
just came to sell it
i wanted to buy a cd and like okay like
we're gonna go in and have this meeting
and like well i'm sure we'll talk about
it we'll figure this all out it'll be
fine and a week later i go in and they
maybe wear like a suit and tie into this
meeting which is like really weird i
walk into a conference room
and it's every teacher i've had for the
past two years no way
sitting around this table and they all
have illegal pads in front of them and
the knife is in the middle of the table
and everyone realizes how big this
[ __ ] knife is
like
you've been seated or no my parents
hadn't seen they're just like that's the
[ __ ] knife
this sword
like where did you get this and i like
tell them like at that flea market
mississippi like years ago like this i'm
sorry but this is just like what i did
this is what i do with my swan and uh
and so they're like we're concerned
about anthony and i'm like listen i
brought the knife to sell i didn't want
to hurt i never yeah i'm not a fighter
like i'm not like i'm not a problem like
that
and they're like yeah but you make a lot
of violent jokes
and i'll never forget the the
my the guidance counselor who's sitting
sitting next to me says you know anthony
when you make these jokes a lot of your
people laugh
but if you look at their reaction after
they stop laughing they're afraid of you
and i'm like and the problem is
like that's cool like that's why i'm not
getting picked on fine
and then they go around and they're like
each teacher would like to say something
and they literally have written down
anything any way i've misbehaved it's a
teacher that i haven't seen in like i
haven't been in class with them in like
a year and a half the [ __ ] gym
teacher
is like listing out things and i'm like
what are you doing
he was like that i was like joking
around like sagging my pants you know
what i mean like as a joke like being
like when like when like criss cross was
like the thing like just doing that like
messing around he's like he broke uh
he broke a street hockey stick one day
and like as if i was doing like over
someone's head it was like no man i just
didn't know how to do a slap shot
yeah i was like i wasn't fighting
getting better equipment you [ __ ] and
then like he wrote this creative writing
story where a guy gets murdered and i'm
like i'm not allowed like the first
thing i teach you in literature class is
author does not equal persona you know
there's a reason they didn't like
[ __ ] throw edgar allen poe in prison
there's a reason stephen king gets to
walk around that i'm like why am i
getting yelled at for this the bosnia
report they're like he talked about this
and detailed this and i'm like
the whole point of that was like we
talked about the holocaust as like never
again but like it's still going on very
much like in well in a lot of different
places like that was the point of this
report why am i being shamed for this
and my parents are humiliated like i'm
more upset but you're not crying you're
defined are you defiant i'm defiant but
when i would get into like in trouble i
was smart about it i wouldn't be like
well [ __ ] you i was just like i was like
you're 100 right i accept my punishment
i won't do it again and i would just go
do whatever i want but in the moment i'm
gonna be like yeah i'm sorry okay take
my lumps and do what i want but as they
go around the room it's just more and
more humiliating that i'm just in shock
at a certain point how many how many
people would you say really get the
sound off in this thing
at least 10. oh my god like math teacher
science teacher lit teacher
um the gym teacher in like in two
different years so they're going on and
they're like kind of riling each other
up to like top each other with different
things and each one of these i'm like
shocked by and they wouldn't have do you
remember them i remember like the ones
that i've told you but they were all
just very like simple like he made fun
of this kid in class and said he would
kill him you know what i mean like just
dumb things like that but it just it
just got worse as it just kept going and
people are like oh yeah i remember this
thing now like you reminded me it was
just completely humiliating everyone so
i just look up my parents and they're
just like
taking this beating and they were good
parents like there wasn't like they
didn't do anything wrong they just and
they didn't deserve this like list of
everything it looks sounds way worse
when you add up two years
into a greatest hits package yeah than
this and again the night it's like this
show people always tell me like i've
never laundry listed my trauma before
and as i'm writing and i look back i'm
like i lived through that like yeah you
lived through that yeah so at the end
they're like do you so we think so wait
can i ask you one question is there
anyone in that room a favorite teacher
that's there to at least say
i know he's a good kid or anyone on that
side of the fence that's like look i
don't want to ruin this kid's life here
no one ever said that but there were
teachers that liked me more than others
but like i'm my literature teacher who
was there that i thought like she's
gonna have my back could not take her
eyes off the knife
like could not like couldn't look me in
the eye because she's just like
yeah well she's just like imagining me
in class running around with this thing
and i'm like that was not what i was
here to do and it doesn't occur enough
to be like guys i was selling it like
why am i in trouble for this if i had
done this off school property this would
be no problem at all like i understand
the word got out but like why are you
making my parents listen to this [ __ ]
but at the end i'll never forget this
they're like
we think you might benefit from therapy
and my family was anti-therapy like i've
been seeing a therapist now for eight
years and i [ __ ] love it yes uh but
at the time it was like something was
wrong with you if you were in therapy
and they're like what do you do you
think you need therapy and i look at my
parents and they're just like
really yeah they were just like dude
like if i had said yes they would have
like gone through with it but they're
just like hoping that i'm like no like
you guys i'm misunderstood i don't have
a problem i mean i wasn't like a sad kid
i was just aggressively dark and and
funny um and uh
and they're like i'm like no
uh i don't i don't think i need therapy
and the guy next to me was the guidance
counselor who was kind of like the good
guy in the room for me you know kind of
like protecting me even though he
probably organized this [ __ ] thing
and he goes well anthony he goes uh i
think you might benefit from some
discipline
and i was like i am about to get hit
like what's going on he goes
what do you think about martial arts and
i just started laughing because i'm like
you [ __ ] want to train me now
like you're gonna use that you guys are
like you can't use the knife but let's
make your hands deadly weapons
and he's like i practice jiu jitsu like
i'm really into it i like i'm learning
japanese i want to go over there like i
take jiu jitsu he's like i can sign you
up for a class and then you and i can
like go out and practice like during
school sometimes we can like work on it
and think that would be like a bonding
thing and i'm like
[ __ ] yeah like this was like right after
steven seagal became a thing yeah when
he just
no one knew no one knew what jiu-jitsu
was and all of a sudden you're just like
this is the baddest [ __ ] out
there like yeah i'll be like him and so
i would they would take me to jiu jitsu
classes and it was so boring i mean it
wasn't like it was the least fun [ __ ]
ever
and uh
and but like every once in a while like
once a week the guidance counselor would
come and be like anthony come with me
and i like changing my gym clothes and
we would like wrestle in the like he
would like show each other different
moves with like arm bars and [ __ ] on the
mat and i'd do that for an hour and then
come back into class but it like made
things a little bit easier but i'll
never forget that like just that
humiliation there and teachers never
looked at me the same luckily i was only
in that junior high for a few more
months and then went on to high school
did that follow you to high school it
followed me that some people like in my
grade like thought i was crazy i thought
i was the crazy one don't mess with him
he's a psycho and i kind of i almost
played into a little bit like i didn't
mind being the crazy one yeah um the
jujitsu though did you find that that
helped you in any way like were you
getting anger out at all or no no it was
more just like embarrassment from this
because it's so you're not learning cool
[ __ ] right you're not liking and
punching exactly yeah and i'm like
wrestling some like a kid who's like
younger than me so it's like am i really
doing anything and i remember uh with
that like i would talk to my friends
about jiu jitsu and they'd be like
anthony's so cocky like anthony thinks
that he could fight anybody because he
takes he's cuz he's a [ __ ] yellow
belt
and did you get a yellow belt in it i
don't think i even got the yellow belt
it was like i missed the day of testing
i was like i'm out of town and they're
like well you gotta wait another three
months and i'm like well i'm not doing
this same [ __ ]
but we're we're walking out of an eaton
park one night
in eden park in pittsburgh is like the
24 hour you know diner uh where like
people go for breakfast and [ __ ] and
they they're open late and my friends
and i are eating one night and we come
out and this van pulls out right in
front of us and these older kids jump
out they're not like big but they're
older from a different town somewhere
and they're like who wants to fight
and my friends kind of like back up but
i'm like kind of [ __ ] jiu jitsu man
like we gotta fight we gotta fight and
the guy goes you think you're tough and
i go i didn't say that man but you know
do what you got to do and he goes like
this like just like the fake punch me
and after
six months of jujitsu training my
response is uh
like i'll never forget putting my arm
like the chicken wing that would that
would not have blocked anything
it would have just taken him right in
the face
and the sound i made i'll never forget
this sound i made
and the guy doesn't swing at all they
are laughing
maybe even a little more high pitched
and they they did the guys just laugh
get back in the van and drive away
and i turn around and look at my friends
and they're not even making fun of me
they're just like and i'm like i can't
believe after six months of training
that that's my reaction that i never did
martial arts ever again
never again yeah i've been boxing and
stuff since this is a workout but like
never
yeah it doesn't work out but that's not
the same as some man on the street who
doesn't know you give a [ __ ] about you
and just wants to take your life
boxing when you learn boxing like the
more you learn the more you'd like no
you just don't know anything yeah i'm
like
you would think working out would make
you better at this i just know that
anyone could kick my ass because i know
how things work uh roll up into a ball
and curl up but so after this thing goes
on like my family and i never talk about
it again so i'm going to talk about that
so they don't make you do therapy
they're really against the therapy yeah
they just thought it meant like they
they failed this pain
so how do they feel about you doing it
now
i did it honestly to try to
get rid of the stigma in my family like
just to be like guys listen i do this
it's great and now some of my siblings
see a therapist
some don't my parents still want nothing
to do with it
and i'm like it would really benefit
like it's just talking to someone
they're not prescribing me pills yeah
and you also have to do it forever go do
it for six months and see how you feel
about it you know and then maybe you
like it but also that's the thing about
therapy is it is like dating i've i had
a therapist one time my first section
this [ __ ] grabbed a sandwich and
started eating i was like are you eating
right now during this he said yeah i
haven't had dinner i go me either
me [ __ ] either but i'm not eating
here right now this is my time like
but why don't you budget a half hour for
yourself before i get here and eat your
[ __ ] sandwich that would be yeah that
would be a deal break that was the deal
break i've been with my same one the
whole time that i'm like i wonder if
like i think she's great i know friends
who see her i know like i've been
recommended by a friend
one's like oh she's the best and i'm
like i assume you're the best but i
don't know and you don't like cheat on
your therapist it would be like i'm
going to take a break or whatever but
i'm like i'm just going to stick with
you until you retire and then i'll never
see a therapist right yeah if it works
it works if it doesn't you got to find
one yeah but i had to like even tell my
parents like it's not me complaining
about my childhood you know it's not
like
my family messed me up they did not mess
me up uh it's like how do i deal with
stuff in the now and it's like almost
looking at your family and seeing why
you do the things you do but not in a
negative light you know they'll be like
you know
it's hard for you to relate to your dad
because your dad's like an attorney in
pittsburgh you're a comedian in los
angeles but if you look at your dad's
life his father was a rail road worker
who went to world war ii you know you
and your dad like
did the opposite and went to like notre
dame on a rotc scholarship and became a
lawyer and now like does he didn't
follow your dad into his dad into the
railway like you're very much like your
father because of this and i'm like i've
realized things like that so they're
like oh okay i'm not just being like one
time my mom didn't get me the birthday
present i wanted like it's not about
that no at all so i
i don't think they'll ever do it um but
my sister i have a sister who's gone uh
brother who's gone and they love it they
absolutely love it yeah i don't think
they would have ever done it if i hadn't
uh just kind of i i i tell everyone they
should see it there i agree i preach it
on this show that whole machismo
[ __ ] like it blows me away when i go
to therapist and i've been to plenty of
them because some of them there are
different types too dr drew had sent me
to this uh emdr therapist which i had
never done that type of therapy the
therapy i had done over years is they
call talk therapy i had never done this
thing with the buzzing and the work in
the sides of my brain and [ __ ] and i was
like well you know just different things
but still to hear that
we as men are
a small minority of the people they see
you know blows me away in 2021 that that
that's still the case and
uh there's nothing wrong with it and
like you said it's not about
my dad beat me and didn't love me and
didn't get enough i mean for some people
it is for sure i was part of that but
now
it's let's not live there anymore we've
understood what that is but to hear that
i think that's really interesting
because my grandfather i was gonna say
baltimore pittsburgh very similar types
of towns blue collar steel back then my
my grandfather worked at bethlehem steel
went to world war ii
um and my father was like nah he got
drafted but after that went and worked
um for pan am you know didn't want to go
just you know be handling steel and [ __ ]
so and then i see that and i'm like yeah
i don't want to be but i've never looked
at it like that makes us similar i've
always looked at it like well i'm
different than my dad because he did
this and i do this but yeah no you're
not you're the same because it propelled
you to do something different yeah
you're not liking you're not just
if i had gone and been a lawyer with my
dad and like formed our own firm that
wouldn't have been what my dad would
have done you know no and like my dad
was very okay with me not going to law
school it was like that i thought he
would have may have forced it like such
a [ __ ] my dad was a big notre dame
guy and i was like are you cool if i
don't even apply and he was like oh yeah
totally like the school i don't want my
daughter to do comedy if you had kids
would you want them to be comedians dude
honestly i'll go i'll do i'll do one
better if i was graduating college right
now i would not get into stand-up comedy
i think it's changed so much that like
kids now i'd be like
i mean like go ahead and [ __ ]
tick-tock it up if you want but like
it's it seems it's that seems terrible
all the all those tik-tok kids seem like
they're going off a cliff
like i can't so is the guy who brought
the crocodile dude [ __ ] sword to
goddamn school so like so this this
happens and i try i try to get over but
i have this anger from that moment like
that all the anger i kept from school
i'd like them just telling me what to do
because i feel like school a lot is like
we're not trying to teach you we're
trying to like wrangle you yes until
you're 18 and then we don't give a [ __ ]
we're proud if you make it but like we
just need to keep you off the streets
kind of and to keep you out of our hair
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next spots are candid now
there's a specialist for just about
everything right when my car breaks down
i go to a mechanic when there's a
problem with my shower i call a plumber
so when you want to get your uneven
crooked teeth fixed you see an
orthodontist they're the specialist and
that's what sets candid the invisible
comfortable and removable aligners above
the rest while poorly reviewed or
insanely priced clear aligner companies
use general dentist candid only works
with orthodontist with candid the same
orthodontist who created your plan is
with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing
all right your treatment is prescribed
and closely monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist who's an expert in
tooth movement you can book an
appointment at a candid studio near you
or you can do everything from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
the average candid treatment is just six
months and you'll start seeing results
way before then and it costs thousands
less than traditional braces and with
your aligner treatment you get a free
candid teeth whitening candid can help
you get the straighter brighter smile
you've always wanted right now you can
get started from home for just 20 with a
candid starter kit or you can book an
appointment at a candid studio near you
today go to candidco.com
and use the code honeydew all right
that's candid co dot com slash honeydew
code honeydew c-a-n-d-i-d-c-o
all right take advantage of this limited
time offer for a 20 starter kit candid
co.com honeydew code honeydew let's tell
you about our next sponsor manscape
detention listeners across the galaxy
all the way from australia to houston do
we have
a pube problem if so our friends at
manscaped have cleared you for takeoff
with their fourth generation in brand
new lawnmower 4.0 kick your pubes to the
next planet with the performance package
4.0 the orbits in your pants will feel
like you're in a zero gravity when you
use the best tools for the job from the
leaders in male grooming join the two
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped and get your rocket ready for
takeoff by going to manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code honeydew all right i've talked to
you about this before man i use these
old trimmers man my balls are tattered
like my taint's all banged up nicked up
everything hurts it's bleeding it's not
pretty you're trying to make yourself
look good and you end up
tattering your taint so if you're ready
for an outer world experience fellas
look no further than the performance
package 4.0 from manscape that has just
taken off in not only the usa but canada
the uk across europe australia south
africa and singapore everybody's getting
their balls in shape inside this package
you'll find their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
their weed whacker ear and nose trimmer
their crop preserver ball deodorant
their crop reviver toner their
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold your whole solar system
abort harry balls and buzz lightyear
that woody with manscaped get 20 off
plus free shipping with the code
honeydew at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code
honeydew at manscape.com your dick and
balls need some help for a clean trinity
and beyond your space balls will thank
you now let's get back to the do
so
uh i go to college i enjoy college i
come out to la i eventually get into
stand-up after about a year and i still
a lot of my stand-up comes from that
anger that i'm like i gotta prove these
people wrong because they're like you're
wasting your life by making jokes in
class i was like i'm gonna if i became a
lawyer i would have i would have proven
you right if i did anything else i would
have proven you right that i'm going to
become a comic and i have no plan b and
that like i've refused to fail at this
i'll find some way to succeed in this
business you can do it through
podcasting do it through writing
producing there's so many different
things you can do that's right but i was
very much like i'm going to be dark
because it comes naturally to me and i'm
going to be smart because i'm smart and
i'm going to like show you that i can
pull this off
and
a couple years like 10 years into
stand-up i get my first tv show the
justin like offensive great i'm working
for comedy central thank you
and
at the end of the first season
and the ratings are great the first
season we're after tosh it's doing well
um
i get in trouble for this thing this
shark party thing that was kind of like
a uh i did this bit where i wanted to i
remember the boss the marathon trouble
yes so in the middle of the first season
i wanted to do a thing where we
celebrate a shark attack oh and the
point being that like we kill hundreds
of millions of sharks a year we're like
driving them to extinction eight people
die a year from shark attacks but
everyone's afraid so when the next time
there's a shark attack we're gonna
celebrate and give you all this
information and jokes but we're doing
like a dance i had like like a bunch of
dancers out there and like a girl
wearing a shark costume giving me a lap
dance and like and it was crazy net but
at the end
of the bit
we showed the guy's picture
and i had asked i was like are we about
to show the guy's picture and they're
like oh yeah you can the comedy central
was like yeah you can and then we did
that and it like everything went to hell
where we thought it was gonna be the
thing that would like launch the show
and then quickly we had to bear it
because new zealand where the guy was
from went crazy really because they got
it online they've released it online and
the rest of the episode they don't know
who i am you know i was i would say like
i would joke like if this happened in
florida
americans would have been like that's
what anthony does but because it was new
zealand they went nuts so viacom is
hearing from people like why like why
are you doing this my family is getting
threats because if you look up anthony
juesselnick in the phone book you get my
dad
so they're calling him at like four in
the morning yeah with a new with a new
uh new zealand accent they can't
understand the afternoon
and
that happened and then at the end of the
season i did the boston marathon bombing
tweet where this is like a couple days
before the show it's not even on the
show i'm just like tweeting because
thinking like this will promote the show
oh the show hadn't launched yet before
before on tweet it was before the last
episode we did it every week we would
tape it on tuesday it would air on
thursday and or maybe the other way
around and uh
and we're just we're getting ready for
the last one i tweet this thing
and then all hell breaks loose it was
like if i had waited 20 minutes i would
have gotten a call from my manager
saying like the head of comedy central
had asked you don't tweet anything about
this today you know wait and i but i
didn't get that message until afterwards
well they got to get up early you know
what i understand yeah and then it was a
fight about like you've got to you've
got to you've got to get rid of this and
there's one person in particular at the
network who was like furious who i had
never met because the networks do you
have lunches with people you bond so
that when they tell you you can't do
something you don't lose your mind
because the comic no one is no one tells
you anything you have a tv show it's
like all these rules all of a sudden
and they're like blaming it all in this
one person
so i take the tweet down i feel bad i
feel embarrassed that i've like put my
crew in jeopardy that anything that i'm
like i put the show in jeopardy with
just a dumb tweet that i didn't care
about although i stand by it i stand by
the joke i thought i did the joke in in
the right way
um
and after the season's over they're like
you've gotta have a meeting we're
picking you up for season two but you've
gotta have a meeting with this this
person and like the other people
and i go in and they're like at first
it's gonna be like they're one they
basically wanna yell at you for writing
this tweet but by then it's been like
two weeks
and everyone kind of feels dumb they're
like the joke wasn't that bad like
the marathon wasn't that bad you know
what i mean it wasn't like it's crazy it
wasn't 911 it was just like it was
horrible but like people got over it
pretty quickly that it wasn't this this
it wasn't like george floyd you know
that would still be sensitive weeks
later
and i they're like you know what it's
more of a glad-handing meeting it's not
really going to be we don't have to talk
about this tweet at all they just
wouldn't come in like i think if you
meet with this person they'll see that
like you're a good person everything
will be okay
and i get into the meeting
and i'm a little nervous i'm a little
like like upset i don't have to be there
but it's like five people in the meeting
like the five heads of comedy central
and like one of my hands the amount in
this [ __ ] knife meeting so you're
doing good bro you're doing good as you
grow and the guy starts the meeting and
he's like so
like first i come in like one person
hugs me and i'm like why'd you touch me
i'm like is this everything are we just
gonna laugh about stuff and they're like
so like dude right now i'm hoping you
[ __ ] say they put that knife from
[ __ ] i mean i
might as well expected it because
they're like listen
shark party was a huge mistake you know
you shouldn't be doing things like that
and i'm like [ __ ] you everyone
was so excited about shark week you're
like this is going to put the just like
offensive on the map like this is the
different thing we're doing this is all
the way to the top they're doing it as
if it was like and i started to get a
flashback to
being in that room with the knife where
they're going around and listing
different parts of the show and the one
woman's like you know one time you
mentioned like a guy who killed a bunch
of kids and then went like this and like
you should and i'm like you know like
you're
giving me [ __ ] about like who i am the
guy that you hired because he did so
well on the roasts and like doing a show
we're talking about these awful things
but you're like still attacking me then
i start [ __ ] sweating like i'm just
like i'm just getting like more and more
grave then i'm like am i about to quit
the show and no one quits a show after
the first season it's like i can't walk
away from this money it's like a dumb
career move but i'm eating
bags of [ __ ] in this and they're like
they're smiling as they're saying this
to me and all i'm thinking of is i am in
their principal's office we're like i
can't talk like i can't say anything to
them i'm just like
okay
all right and like everything's good i'm
like everything's great like let's just
get into that second season and get over
this
that i was like truly truly devastated
and truly felt like principal's office
why did you have me why did you have
this meeting like to see how mad you
could make me and i even at the end i go
into an explanation of like why i do
what i do like why i make these horrible
jokes and how it actually is
life-affirming and i'm trying to make
fun of like the worst things in the
world and the person in charge is like
smiling and nodding and then a few weeks
after this
we have a meeting about season two
what's gonna go on
and they're like what changes are you
gonna make
and i'm like well you know like the way
i explained to so and so you know we're
not making any changes i thought i
explained why i do this and now i can do
this and they go
no
but
she was smiling and nodding and they go
she was just smiling and nodding you
didn't change your mind
and now i'm like literally like there's
a five minute pause where i stare at the
table and think about blowing it all up
think about being like i'm out of here
this is huge like why i'm going back on
the road this is humiliating my manager
afterwards was like do you still want to
do the show and i'm like i can't walk
away from there's too many employees
there's too many people i can't i can't
do it but it was like it took maybe like
five or six years to even be able to
talk to anyone at company central again
and now we're friends now we're cool
everything is okay but it was really
like
just feeling like going from being like
you're a famous comedian now you've made
it you've done it to you're in eighth
grade
getting [ __ ] on by all your teachers and
the people who are supposed to be like
looking out for you that it was it took
i was in therapy about that for years
and like thoughts and prayers my special
the reason the last 20 minutes is about
that was because i'm like i've got to
get this [ __ ] off my chest and change
the narrative like people out there
think that i got canceled because of
shark party the way that the story is
told because it's at the end but it's
like no i got cancelled because the
ratings tanked in season two
and i was difficult to deal because i
was just so mad at everybody they didn't
want to give me notes because i would
like i was so aggressive in taking notes
because i just still felt the trauma of
that meeting where when they talk about
that show failing they talk about that
meeting that like that meeting was a
mistake and if that hadn't happened
maybe
maybe if i hadn't made the tweet you
know maybe that i would have been in a
better mood in season two and it would
have kept going but uh
yeah that was that was just a back
breaker it was brutal and then
i i kept that anger
and
a couple years ago
the school gets in touch with me and
they say we now have an alumni hall of
fame
we've been doing for the past like 10 15
years we would like to induct you tell
him to get the seventh grader right your
ass out to [ __ ] take that [ __ ]
trophy but they were like we want we
want to do this will you come to the
ceremony if we do it i go oh [ __ ] yeah
i'll be there yeah and they're like do
you want to talk to the students and i
was like [ __ ] yeah i want to talk to the
students
i'm like i'm like
i'm coming in like a [ __ ] ninja to
that man everybody
but i get up there to talk to the kids
and i walk in like the principles are my
age you know now it's like a different
people are there any teachers that are
still there from your time no one's
there people showed up for the
ceremony at night to like see if they
get a shout out or whatever there were a
couple of them that i was like i
remember you and like thank you for this
and they just come just to see the
students but no one's still there at
that school
and uh the principal's like
you know this is there's like 13 year
old because no one gives me like talks
about what i'm gonna say or anything
they're just like you have 13 year olds
in here and i'm like yeah pg-13 i'll
just say [ __ ] once and they're like i'm
like i'm kidding like i'm kidding
i'm gonna say it a bunch but then i get
up there
i get up there at this podium
and i realize none of the these kids are
like they look like muppets to me like
i'm like i don't relate to you i thought
it would be cool to come back and be
like you you don't they don't know who i
am like they didn't know i was a
comedian they didn't know like i had a
tv show they don't know any of this
stuff so i'm just like bombing in front
of a bunch of kids like trying to tell
them to like follow your dreams or
whatever it couldn't have gone worse and
then i'm like oh my god take questions
and they're like this uh this foreign
exchange student goes uh
i assume this phone exchange dude just
goes like who are you
and then everyone laughs or and i go you
wouldn't be able to pronounce it and
then the class is like oh and i'm like
yeah let's see this is what i do come on
and then somebody and then i see the
principal like kind of getting closer to
the stage like we got to wrap this up
you're like
nothing and they go who are you voting
for hillary or trump and this is like
the very beginning of it and i go
hillary
and they start going trump trump
i'm like kids really kids kids and then
they're like this is over this is over
this is done
there's a trump chat at your [ __ ] so
i believe
i leave and i go and i come back at
night for the ceremony where they they
give me like a speech about everything
i've accomplished and i get up and the
other people are like they're because
they're like still good at math and [ __ ]
or like an engineer like a tennis player
who's done something or a musician who's
going on but no one that's currently at
your level of their respect for the
field yes everyone they were like keep
your speech to five minutes anthony do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you know did
you go last that went in the middle and
the guy after me his whole speech was
about how hard it was to go after me
but i'm like i'm the truly the
i'm the i i appreciate this more than
anyone else here like i understand you
guys are like this is nice but like some
of them were like we don't give a flying
[ __ ] what do i care about my high school
thinks of what but i was like i'm you're
giving me this for everything you begged
me not to do for the entire time i was
at the school that's right like i got
this by saying by ignoring everything
you've ever said to me
ever
like thank you and i called out a couple
teachers that i liked and was just truly
thrilled that like all the anger just
went away it was like i just ended up
outlasting them and proving them right
that it felt uh it felt really good yeah
and now like i've got to find other ways
to write stand up because it used to
just be like going back to that
yeah
yeah
it was full circle that's [ __ ] great
dude
um i do want to i want to go a little
lighter and hear about this airport
story that you told me you had okay so
we've got we've got just about time
correct and this is just embarrassing
it's not dark we love this it's
embarrassing so
when i'm on the road
i try to enjoy myself where i can you
know what i mean like i don't drink on
the flight to the gig but on the way
back from the gig i'm i'm i'm in first
class i'm i'm drinking the free vodkas
and uh and i know i just i get there
there's a car waiting to pick me up i'm
cool but i get [ __ ] up and i'm always
nice i would the idea of being like mean
to a flight attendant or any of that
[ __ ] is just like beyond me that i'm
with you on that like what are you doing
but i had gotten this weed pen
and it was like this disposable weed pen
it was like this it's like the most
expensive one they had it's a little
vape thing and you like hit it and like
three seconds later excuse me it buzzes
and you blow up this tiny bit of like
indecipherable vapor you get a little
bit high and i'm like telling i'm like
you got to try this this doesn't set off
smoke alarms you can smoke it in an
airplane bathroom and everyone's like oh
wow cool anthony like that's your thing
but i would but i would do it sometime i
would do it unlike every flight almost
even if i wasn't drinking but this
flight i'm pretty lit up and we're
flying from denver to l.a and about the
halfway point and i've gone to the
bathroom several times to hit this thing
and you're at first class so you're
going right up front by the cockpit yeah
right by the cockpit
and again there's like less people use
that bathroom i'd be more afraid to use
one where there's like a line because
i've hit it before and i've hit it like
a bunch of times and then blown it out
and opened the door
and there's somebody walking in there
like what the [ __ ] but they don't think
like they don't put two and two together
and okay no one's gonna call you out in
first class
but i'm in there and i hit it like just
like once or twice like not like like
i'm trying to like blow it up in here
but like i know you try a little bit let
it go through your nose a little bit
yeah and i like it i blow like into the
toilet as i flush it
and i'm blowing it out and i'm right
about i'm like washing my hands and just
i just hear
and it's not and it's like the lights in
the bathroom in there and i know it's me
it's not wait we got turbulence i know
it's me and i'm just like
[ __ ]
and i'm just humiliation is all i'm
feeling and i'm like if they land this
plane
if they ground this flight from me
that will be this will be the worst day
of my life that like
i i can't imagine facing people or like
inconveniencing people like
that it would be the worst thing ever so
i opened the door
and i'm like maybe this will be fine you
know because like it's just a little bit
of vape it's like i'm smoking a
cigarette i open the door and i'm in
like seat 3a it's one of those where
it's like i've got i'm on like i have my
own little aisle thing i just get out
and i get in and no one's looking at me
everyone's kind of looking around like
what's this
so is it going on through the whole
plane not just in the band not just in
the bathroom the whole plane and it's
loud it's loud so no one's looking about
everyone's looking around like what the
hell and the flight attendants are in
the back with the drink cart and i just
want to get in the thing and say like
please do not smoke or vape in the in
the bathroom and one of them runs up
into the bathroom and it like turns off
the alarm right away and it's kind of
like
i kind of smell something and
i would have been fine
except
i think
let me handle this and i hit the call
button
let me let me take care of this
i'm like um
again i've had a few drinks i've had a
couple hits of this weed
and and she comes over and i'm like hey
i was in there when that went off like i
was just watching i don't know what
happened i was just washing my hands
why i did that i have no idea i assumed
like didn't with them looking for me or
like i was trying to hide something uh
like being ashamed and she's like uh-huh
like that [ __ ] thing doesn't go off
when you're washing your
and they walk away and they're just
she's like what were you doing in there
and i was like no i was washing my hands
walks away and i'm just like playing
game on my phone i'm like i can't ask
for another drink i'm just like you're
done yeah no one and no one's really
looking at me too much and i just grown
the beard so i'm like thank god like
maybe i have this cover because and i
don't want to see people tweeting just
like just set off the alarm
and they keep going for a little bit and
i'm like okay they're not going to land
this plane we're going to go all the way
to la where it took a four hour it's
like a three hour flight or something
we're halfway there they're going to
keep going i'm like okay i'm relaxing a
little bit and the flight attendant
comes back over and she kneels down she
goes i just have to ask you know what
were you doing like exactly
i have to ask were you vaping or smoking
in the bathroom and i'm just too
embarrassed to say to say yes at this
point like just it i should have found a
lot like listen i don't want to make
your job harder but like yes i was i hit
the vape pen i'm like no
and she's like what were you doing like
washing my hands okay but in a way that
i know she does not believe with the
rolling lips
so my [ __ ] like i'm just sitting there
waiting for this to land and then right
before like like we're landing in about
15 minutes she walks up with a piece of
paper and she said this is from the
captain
and it says like you are in violation of
federal law
uh for like like smoking or vaping in a
bathroom you might when we land you must
um like like
go through this investigation cooperate
with the investigation when we land
otherwise blah blah and i'm like okay
is this the punishment you know i mean
is it just like showing me this and then
we get off and everything's fine or what
so she comes back and i know that like
when i've heard of things going down on
airplanes where it's like they they're
in the news it's because they're dicks
to the flight attendant right you know
they get obliged and i'm like she walks
back and i go thank you very much i
understand and then the plane lands and
we're taxing and the pilot's like we're
about to pull into the gate here uh
before anyone gets up we've got a little
business we've got to take care of first
and i like know i'm [ __ ] so i'm
texting my opener in the back oh my god
is your stomach i'm getting nervous over
here so like i just don't know and i
don't know what i'm in for all right
i'm texting the opener i'm like hey i
just got busted vaping in the bathroom
like i don't know what's about to happen
to me but like
like we'll see
we pull up uh two cops get on the flight
the pilot comes out the pilot looks like
he's [ __ ] 25 years old he looks like
a california surfer kid he's smiling he
walks up with a flight attendant they're
talking i'm sure they were like how is
he acting you know what i mean like is
this how bad do you want to be about
this i'm sure they're like he was nice
whatever
and then they the cops get on and
everyone's kind of looking around like
what's who is this what's going on and
they come on and they start yelling
three a
no three a all down the
with your eyes closed
and i'm like yeah it's me and they go
get your things and come with us
two cops two cops and are they lax cops
or are these like lapd cops i assume
there were lapd cops like uh who worked
at lax so maybe there was like a yeah
something in between but they weren't
just like it wasn't like security guards
are you nervous as [ __ ] yes because i
just don't know and i'm like i'm like my
plan is just to totally come clean look
like i imagine also you're like me you
got your tsa pre-check is probably in
jeopardy and all that [ __ ] now yeah
clear if you have that yeah
is american airlines gonna kick me off
like what's going on but i know i'm in
first class so that carries some weight
i get my bag
and i get off and we walk down this
thing i'm like where are we going am i
going into some dark room like are they
putting me in a car and we just walk
into the [ __ ] gate like where
everybody else is going to walk out they
just make a guy move his laptop and they
pull me aside and they're like what
what happened and i go i vaped in the
bathroom like and i like i didn't throw
away the pen i didn't try to hide it i
was like i taped in the bathroom but i'm
talking about weed
and the guy's like
like okay let me see your id he's
looking at it as he's doing this people
are coming off the plane looking at me
so i'm trying to be like
yeah
yeah i know
total misunderstanding like i'm i'm
trying just like if you if you were like
like i'm a beautiful
picture
maybe he like the cop knew him was
helping him out
and he's like okay well you know like
you know uh it's it's a you know it's a
three-hour flight you should be a
nicotine addiction is a serious thing
but you should be able to i'm like oh no
i was coming from denver and he's like
nicotine addiction he's like trying to
help me he's like [ __ ] stop
telling me it's weird
and uh and like just takes my id
he's like we're not gonna punish you
no warrants or anything hands me a day
back he's like we're not going to take
them you actually ran your name to see
if you had any warrants out and they did
all that oh they were waiting on you
like wait i think that's just what they
did we're going to give you a warning
but in case you're [ __ ] wanted man
we're going to get you but i was clean
and he's like i don't know if american
airlines is going to get in touch and do
anything but as far as we're concerned
like you're you're free to go
and this point my opener's gotten off
and she's like she got in the pilot's
face and was like where is he what and
the pilot laughter was like he's fine
he's out there and i thought about
waiting for a little bit to like when
the flight attendant can't have to go up
and apologize to be like i know your job
is hard i'm sorry i made it harder but
i'm like if she sees me
with my like vodka pod eyes coming at
her she's gonna think i'm coming to kill
her that i'm like let's leave this alone
but then i've got to walk down with my
opener
and wait for my checked luggage
and everyone is staring at me people are
missing their bags are just going around
the carousel where they're pointing at
me and i'm like i'm like i think i
bought a hat like in the gift shop to
wear
because i just didn't want like i didn't
want like anthony jesselnick you know
does this that for like a week
afterwards
i would be walking around the street
still embarrassed that like people knew
that anyone like i didn't tell the story
for a while and then i told my manager
and she was like her eyes got like huge
and then like six months later she's
making fun of me about it in front of
other people that it was like it became
totally okay but i've nev people are
like do you still vape in the bathroom
i'm like i don't [ __ ] bait man
that scared the [ __ ] out of me that like
i don't bring anything anywhere anytime
i don't even drink on planes anymore
really i drink water because it's like
that would like that was the the
dehydration plus drinking was the thing
that really like got to me that once i
started drinking water it was fine but
after that like i mean total humiliation
just like i can't believe i did this and
thank god again they did not divert the
plan or landed because that would have
been i don't know if i would have flown
again but yeah i mean i learned my
goddamn lesson but it was
humiliating yeah i'll bet i would have
been worried that they ban you lifetime
flying then you're john madden out there
on a tour bus going to all your [ __ ]
gigs only like oh my god and that's what
happened with cigar yeah yeah tell me
what happens that's why he does it yeah
i don't know what to do with my pre or
any of that but they i mean they didn't
care i remember i got back and i texted
ron functions and i'm like you're the
only person i know who needs this
information but because i'm like you
seem like the kind of guy who would also
vape in the airport i don't even [ __ ]
with that yeah and i was like i was like
did this happen they [ __ ] pulled me
off the plane like didn't cuff me or
anything but like it was embarrassing he
goes good to know and he was like lucky
you got white privilege
and i go dude
it was first class privilege like white
that white was like that nothing to do
with it it was strictly like the year
three rows back we're gonna give you
some grace but yeah if you're in a
situation like that just be as nice as
possible and do not
draw attention to yourself
and say let me explain what happened
they're like we didn't want to we didn't
want to know who it was that's the truth
we didn't even i didn't want to deal
with this
that's why she was like i have to ask
you yeah
yeah i'm so so stupid but yeah that was
true that was that's the last time i've
been like truly humiliated like what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah in your 40s this
is less than two years ago maybe 39
at the time it was my last tour but uh
but yeah i just thought like you did
this to yourself and again like if i
would have given anything to turn back
time and not have that happen you know
like it was just what a kick in the
teeth god damn i would be just oh the
heat on the inside of my body would have
melted me in that [ __ ] seat they
wouldn't have to worry about anything
but you've never seen anyone like soak
into their game of bejeweled
than i was like i was just sitting there
like playing it like
like
he couldn't have done anything wrong
look how into his [ __ ] game he was he
wouldn't be just playing a game if uh
because i was like too [ __ ] up to read
a book
um
all right before we wrap this up i told
you uh when we got in here advice you
would give to your 16 year old self i'm
curious going back now
uh especially after hearing your speech
for your high school and things what
advice you would give to yourself it was
an interesting question for me because i
used to always like when i was even
struggling as a stand-up like you know
in my 20s when you're just not making
any money you're just doing it
every birthday i would think i was i'm
always happier to get older but every
birthday i would go back and i would
think what would if i went back in time
right now to my 18 year old self would
they think i was cool and the answer was
always yes like you're like you're
you're following your dreams your stand
up you've gotten like to do a show with
sarah silverman whatever it was i was
like you would think you were cool [ __ ]
you and then i got to be like 36 and i
remember thinking back like now i'm
double that age and i go
what do i give a [ __ ] what 18 year old
me thinks about anything or any 18 year
old thinks about anything like that's
stupid
that to go back to a 16 year old it's
hard to say like don't worry about these
things because worrying about it is what
made me who i am it's like if i had been
like forget about school like don't
don't sweat these small things uh
everything's gonna work out all right it
wouldn't have you know if my parents had
been more supportive of my comedy and of
my writing hey therapy at that moment
might not have might have changed
everything it might have changed it
might have changed things but but
probably would have made me more
adjusted and i wouldn't be a stand-up
like that's what i mean whatever road
got me to where i am today i'm happy i
was on that road i wouldn't change
anything so it's almost like i wouldn't
[ __ ] with him you know i wouldn't like i
wouldn't tell him anything but if i was
gonna tell him something it would be
like
you're right
enjoy
enjoy it
you know
i want to say stevens it up i i look i
think that is great advice actually but
i want to say this when it comes to the
16 and the 18 year olds i mean at least
for me
i was a comedy fan back then i don't
know if you are i know some comedians
weren't comedy fans i was always a
comedy fan comedy fan so
when i get young kids that hit me up now
i think oh yeah i was in [ __ ] ninth
grade listening to a gray-haired george
carlin you know an older richer i mean
eddie murphy was like the only anomaly
that was even relatively close to our
age who was that but
um
i don't want to forget about us as those
kids now the life advice yeah but
what i do care about is what they think
about my comedy yes you know what i'm
saying i want them to laugh and think
it's cool but if they don't like that's
okay yeah like and they're a little more
sensitive these days they're definitely
way more so that they're that into me or
some might be
i think my audience is generally older
uh luckily they're older and wealthy um
which i enjoy but i enjoy it i i heard
once like stanhope said like if you tell
if you give a comic advice you're just
telling them how to be more like you
yeah like someone reached out the other
day and was like hey i've got a friend
who's like doing stand-up in pittsburgh
and i want to take the next step and i
was like listen man like i'm the i've
been doing this 20 years things are way
different now than it's like i don't
want to tell you not to do tick-tock i
would never do that but i wouldn't tell
you not to because maybe that's your
thing that i don't want to like give you
bad advice right you know the advice i
would say like the movie comedian
watch the movie comedian the jerry
seinfeld documentary that kind of taught
me everything there was to know that's
like a helpful way to be like just keep
writing and working and like embrace
failure i guess i would just say embrace
failure and maybe not too much like you
want it to hurt because if it stops
hurting then then you're it does you
know it's not gonna have the same effect
like i go up with new jokes today and
like they bomb and that makes me go home
and write new ones i don't just keep
doing the same set of [ __ ] that works
that uh i don't know if that's advice i
would give but i get it a lot i get
people back home they're like what about
this and i'm like look i it's this is
gonna sound like i'm being a dick
but the only way to do stand-up is to do
it period i i don't believe in taking a
class i believe if robin williams taught
a comedy class we wouldn't have a chris
rock or a dave chappelle because people
would think that's what comedy is
saying
what was it for though i didn't stand up
comedy class but what was it
like a basic like before you ever
started comedy or were you already
income it was like it was like i'm too
scared to go to open mic let me do this
like the guy had written a book greg
greg dean i went into this class and
then i did the second one and then like
realized like i don't want to do like it
was like learn the rules to know how to
break them the kids who just go up there
and it's like anarchy on stage it's like
you don't know the rules right it's it's
subversive if you're bending the rules
and you know them and what they are but
if you have no idea then it's just it's
not that fun you know i took the it was
like a free intro class and my question
to him was who are you what that kid
asked you and he said it's a great
question this is who i am he had taught
whoopi goldberg or something like that
and i was like
yeah i get it his whole thing was
make sure you're doing the setup punch
and and go for a left turn on that punch
don't just see take the
you know first one that's our job is to
go way deeper than the average person
would and also still make it funny and
relatable i call it third thought that's
our job like everyone would like first
thought is like that's what anyone would
think second thoughts like if you took a
second you would get it that's an okay
joke third thought is like [ __ ] like
totally caught me off guard that's great
his thing for us was because you're
teaching like all these different people
and most of them are hopeless but you've
got to teach them all so it's like talk
about your life you know only you have
your experiences and deal with the crowd
in front of you you know don't just like
just rehearse the same set you're not
doing a movie like deal with the crowd
in front of you you gotta do crap do
what you have to do yeah be present but
none of those people are doing anything
nothing one of them owns flappers i
think
[Music]
dude thank you so much for coming on um
please promote your podcast again
whatever you want
jaisal nick and rosenthal vanity project
jrvp uh it's just silly it's wacky uh
people seem to like it and if you like
my comedy uh people people enjoy seeing
a different side of me well very dark
i've enjoyed this seeing a different
side of you too so thank you so much as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you